it's live stream this is a one of a
continuing series of meetings about the
quantum computing capabilities that we
are building for from language these may
show up is an actual built-in feature of
the language or they may show up first
as a package and it's been a little
while since we met about this but we are
going to see what has happened here so
let's start off do we have an example of
what happened to my screen there okay so
what is this thing about removed wire
names so last time part of our
discussion centered around the fact that
a previous version of this package
required you to specify names for the
wires for each part of your quantum
state or you know which wires are
quantum objects that was calling them
you were quantum operations we're acting
on yeah and we decided that that was
probably not the best thing to do and in
fact after a lot of thinking it seemed
best to get rid of the wire names
entirely and in fact I'm looking at
other quantum computing packages like
for instance quantum information science
kit in Python they just use numbers for
everything oh just have different
constraints they don't have a symbolic
language they don't really go to do much
else so computation completely
everything is still symbolic it just
didn't make sense to use names for the
wires
oh yeah well let's see how you actually
represent a circuit then where is okay
so here you're trying to say I don't
even know what this is so these these
the actual diagrams that we had figured
out no so that's just a holdover for a
generic quantum circuit the diagram is
what you see below under a circuit
diagram okay so let me see how you build
that up and that that looks like named
was to me ABC whatever so that's so you
in the quantum circuits
you can actually specify you can use an
option to specify names for that go
along with each of the wires in the
circuit diagram okay but okay so let me
let me see how we're now building how
you're now proposing to build these
things up I'm not seeing where a quantum
circuit where is there an example of a
quantum circuit here so the first one
circuit is right there circ one okay so
what does this mean so that means that
you have a policy context operation
which is earlier on in the notebook and
at Offaly operation and the c-max
operates on the first qubit and the
toefl II act on the second third and
fourth qubits and we really think that
this arrow okay so let's find out what
your X actually is okay so your X is
Sigma X all right so let's take a look
at that so that represents that matrix
operation parity is one right it's
hermitian yes it's unitary yes okay so
that's an example of its matrix
representation that's dandy and and then
beforehand at one point you had to do
lots of weird things to specify what the
cuticle was but now the default is two
because qubits are most free believe
this is nice yeah that's nice mm-hmm and
this this format that I'm using now
quantum matrix operation I split things
up beforehand I had just quantum finite
dimensional operation and there were
many different things that you could do
in that but it ended up being very
complicated with lots of keywords and
and things like that
so I decided to go with quantum matrix
operation for unit areas but also
nonunitary operations like raising and
lowering operators it looks like s + + s
- mm-hmm and then a different construct
for measurements
that's all you turns out that you need
just those two what's this quantum
planar dimensional state so the
quantified a dimensional state is you
still need something to represent
quantum states and so this right here
says that you're gonna make a quantum
register
has three cubits or three cubits and
they're together they're in the
registers in the five state what do you
mean the five state you mean it's the
state the state um
1:01 or something or what precisely okay
um that's a little weird if I might say
so I mean okay hold on let's go back
here okay so the idea is these are
matrix operations by the way why is C
naught which is capitalized there why is
it not capitalized you can do it either
way so I am i did some take casting
which with no matter how you spell it
like but we need to decide what
canonical it is what would a c not stand
for anyway complimentary not not British
not controlled not right so in our usual
way of doing this so what we do let me
just think what do we do in the boolean
case so in the boolean case when we have
to name things if we say for example
boolean convert um actually use that all
go to that later okay um okay so boolean
convert has this notion of a form and
for its forms it uses the capitalized
versions okay so I think probably what
we should do here does this support the
actual full form controlled not it
probably should okay so we should have a
version by it spelled out and a version
where it's capital C not okay so yes
those are things that I'm that it will
it will support okay so right now like
I'm I think instead of Sigma X for X if
you put in just X or if you put in tally
X I think both of those will work
okay okay nice it might be a little
confusing but I think it's nice and
eventually you know eventually we should
make you know eventually we should do
two actual and with stick
so you can type control equals
controlled knots and get the right thing
I'm sure if I type control equals not I
wonder what on earth happens it's a word
but it's also probably huh fascinating
it doesn't support that being that's
interesting that probably should be
extended to actually switch mode can you
can you make a note of that I mean
that's slightly it's a slightly bizarre
case because I mean if I say something
like P and not Q I'm sure we'll get a
nice result there
go ahead something also which you'll see
later on in the document is the support
for boolean functions in quantum
circuits so it turns out that even for
non reversible classical boolean
functions there is a way and I've
programmed this in to represent those
using reversible quantum circuits and so
one of the examples down below
it's just there's some boolean function
that's given and you say I'm circuit of
boolean function goes to a boolean
function is and it'll generate that for
you like this like boolean function
arrow no arrow you can just put it in
key and ends not queue and it'll do that
how does it know what the variables are
so that's what if it generates the
observer at the quantum circuit where in
the diagram the so okay so it's going to
assume if you say P and n not Q the only
constraints are on P and Q you know fair
enough that so it's gonna name P and Q
right so it's gonna name the variables P
and Q yes whereas whereas in this case
that I'm doing here there's a case where
okay so if I do that how do I get
something out of this if I say matrix
representations and what what kind use
circuit diagram
that's nice so that's a very single one
actually but um right no this is just I
just did the formatting very quickly the
main thing was actually programming at
all because there's only the only
operations logical operations that can
actually be converted to quantum
reversible analogs are XOR and and not
instead you have to make turn everything
into the e sop normal form and boolean
convert and then use the X or you can
basically use a control mod operation to
do XOR and you can use TOEFL e gates to
do and okay but in the end this is okay
we can get to the cinema but in the end
this is not going to be so I put P and Q
in here so that's just represent then
when you actually put a quantum state in
if you don't have to name P and Q it
just it'll assume that you have your I
have a two qubit quantum state that's
input right but is this extra wire
basically a garbage wire to deal with
it's not reversible
no the extra wire is where your result
goes in okay but so so then the the
reversibility is dealt with by having
stuff come out on those who has is that
correct
so P and Q end up being the exact same
as they were before hand the only thing
that changes is the result register but
how can it be reversible so you were
representing these classical boolean
functions using only a bunch of
reversible operations and then you
perform a measurement at the end which
is irreversible yeah but I mean at the
level of this quantum bison you're doing
a measurement on that wire there so the
measurement is on the result register
okay fair enough
okay cool all right I need to understand
a little bit more but let's keep going
on what you were doing here
so if I would just put in a matrix here
that would work to you so if I just say
quantum matrix operation and I do like a
well let's just do I say I do identity
matrix for okay so it didn't like that
so what should I have done here do I now
have to say queued it in order to make
that work like unit dimension goes to -
or key dimension goes to for either one
works no why didn't this look that
should work it's programmed in to work
well let's just try the two case where
we kind of know no something's wrong
okay no matter so this about for now
yeah okay what does this mean so this is
the pure symbolic case or no this is the
case where you already set the value T
no it's been symbolic right there that's
okay doesn't there's no errors or
anything it just keeps it symbolic and
actually for quantum states you can keep
things symbolic even when you're doing
products like tensor products okay all
right so let's take a look at this
creature so this is I think this is
slightly exotic I mean quantum finite
dimensional state okay so you have here
a quantum register what does the three
mean of size of three bit quantum
register mm-hmm yeah it's a little weird
that that is I mean that form so in
general what we would say is you know
something like register length or it's
basically the number of bits and the
register and then register state arrow
and I would have thought it was more
natural to say 1 0 1 although you can
certainly turn the turn that into an
integer but I would say the
that would be a better way to do it this
is something that Jake on and I
discussed recently whether it's better
to have some sort of chronic approach to
these in which everything is flattened
into matrices or rather these other
approaches you're suggesting in which we
still keep the dimensionality the
original dimensionality of things I
think we should support both somehow
just in case let's try to understand
this quantum okay so you've got a
quantum finite dimensional state okay
great and that's the number of those
bits okay fine I mean it would be nice
to know okay so what is the sparse array
here what is that thing so if I if I say
can I say matrix representation of that
thing of the cube as a state vector like
this it's a Q reg of state vector form
you can also do density matrix
incentives okay so I don't understand
that what did this mean so that that is
IC that's the fifth it's in position
five position six because in quantum you
start from zero you can actually also
plug in you can say basis states instead
of state vector you can say basis States
yeah I understand I understand what's
gonna happen here that's far from
wonderful okay I can forget the matrix
form there great but so what I mean it's
in a particular it's in the 1 0 1 that's
the basis state but the question is that
is there a form of this where there's an
association where it says base to state
arrow and then the amplitude that would
get really messy in states that have a
lot of your components well but it's
look this hold on the zero honored
origin thing is going to cause us
trouble so we're gonna have to deal with
that now notice that what we do in the
case of if I say rule plot of that's a
boolean function let's say seven coma -
okay it does it starts with the one one
case here see what I'm saying mm-hmm I
mean it goes from one one down to zero
zero now that means so what that's doing
is okay we have to think about what that
means for these things because it's
obviously just a convention what the
order of this that this thing is indexed
in other words if you take the state
vector and you index into the state
vector what you're really doing is
indexing according to with States into
the state vector and you're not the fact
that those states are encoded by
integers is its own separate kind of
worms making sense so I mean the the
true version of that the representation
of a state might be that cat right and
then then the question of what you
actually get for the fifth element so to
speak other than the quintessence of
antiquity but you know the the fifth
element whatever it is the nth element
here the okay
all right so let's let's keep going and
we're gonna come back to this okay okay
okay so this is a trace what does that
mean so that means you're tracing over
the first qubit right so if you were to
do two in there instead it would give
you a different answer
indeed I would hope that okay fine all
right so yeah what is this this just
says that you can have you can make a
state that has all you know symbolic
coefficients and keeps everything
symbolic for you
and before when we had nested arrays to
represent entangled States this is
automatically representing an entangled
state without any of the nesting that
was calm
before so let me just try to understand
this so this is the Q debt dimension is
to here but what would happen if I just
were to take a single alpha beta here
then it would just be one cute instead
of two okay what if I took three of
those things then it will complain then
you should get in there it's not very
pretty error well so I haven't worked on
that yet it's no okay fine so that so so
what we're doing here is we're
untangling so I think there's going to
be a messy issue of how these things are
numbered okay because what you're doing
here is you're essentially untangling
tuples into this vector right it's just
the same way as the basis states above I
understand that I understand we already
have a convention for doing that in
boolean functions right and the
convention we are doing that in boolean
functions let's take a look at what we
do because okay so let's look at this
let's look at boolean table of P and not
Q for example P Q okay so what that's
saying is false true false false so what
that corresponds to is let's do a
boolean table of P Q so I think it's
gonna say yeah there we go
true true true false false true false
false right now okay I've got two
comments here first of all we need to do
the correct mapping between true/false
and 1 0 and we play need to support true
false as inputs here but let's let's
come to that in a minute
but the main point here is that we're
going from 1 1 down to 0 0 which means
we're alighting the nastiness was 0
Arjun stuff see what I'm saying mm-hmm
which i think is it's better to go the
other way round like this than it is to
have to be off by one
perhaps we can make this configurable
because I it could be that some it its
traditional somewhere to start with zero
ones and then we'd have like at least 0
1 or 1 0 and then you have 1 0 or 0 1
depending on what direct right so it
sounds to me like the convention in
Mathematica is different than the
convention in the traditional quantum
computing literature so maybe I think
what Jose is suggesting is that maybe we
allow an option for what the convention
is yeah I think that will be a mess I
mean I think the question let's work
through it all ok and let's see what we
need to do that right because because
you could say that I mean you know you
notice how boolean functions work right
so what we now have to do to make a
boolean function we're now numbering the
boolean functions right
we're numbering boolean functions
starting from with this ordering of what
the bits mean which is a completely
arbitrary order it right but it's the
same type of thing as you have in the
basis states here anyway let's keep
going I mean I don't think anybody's
probably numbering quantum operators
right now like for example there's a
definite numbering of all the you know
like like I think now I think I'm X or
a7 if I remember correctly so you can
probably see from any of the stuff um ok
so let me try to understand so we have
unraveled the state and term in the same
way as this unravels a state albeit
maybe backwards but we'll worry about
that later
right mm-hmm and then when we say
quantum finite dimensional state what is
thus actual matrix here is the vector
right there that's just those are just
for normalized components it's just
Alpha Beta Gamma Delta divided by the
absolute value ok so this is just alpha
and beta
what is that horribly messy expression
why is it so complicated isn't it just a
AB squared
yes I don't know why it's well so let's
just see what happens if I say full
simplify on that thing so how do i how
do I get that expression out so you can
do full simplify of a symbolic of state
vector wait a minute
this thing here symbolic state vector is
that what you're saying no just you
state vector you can do symbolic okay
okay okay okay
and now I can say normal of that okay so
now let's say for simplify of this I
think there's going to be a problem
because the assumptions were putting
onto alpha and beta no not really
okay so we need to understand why this
got so messed up here yeah I I'll try to
figure that out okay so this is the site
fully understand mm-hmm I'm not sure why
it got so complicated it there's
definitely you know a way to make it
simpler and I just need to figure out
what exactly happened okay fine so you
know going forward
did you just were state specifications
okay by the way somebody on our live
stream is mentioning this is somewhat
similar to the font from boolean
function which we came up with a better
name for and maybe Sushma remembers what
that name was so maybe Jose remembers he
did last decision was to to false
oh yeah true false right to to false to
true false yes that's the last thing we
decided right because we decided that
that and so what that will do is to take
one zero and turn it into 12 false
different there's different operation
from this okay
so now let's go back here so what's
happening to this so these are just sort
of the you know ways
you can specify quantum states okay fine
why does that have to be braces around
these because if you don't have braces
around the outside you could have just
been specifying a symbolic array like we
did in the past case thank you what's
imboca right well if you look at a
quantum finite dimensional state of
alpha and beta if we just had a single
array there we didn't have to then we
wouldn't be able to support potentially
multiple sub states so what you're
saying is so for example if I were to do
a you're saying in this case here I
could do five plus five plus is that
correct there's examples that right
below okay it's so now what does this
mean so five plus is this state which is
into a two qubit state and this is a
fork you yet state um so it just took
the tensor product of those two and now
because you don't have wire names you
don't have any of the you know the
difficulties that come along with that
okay so hold on let me understand this
so if I want to make a circuit out of
this know what am I doing here this
isn't a circuit this is just a state
that's some kind of okay direct product
state so for example for that I don't
know what this is why they're only four
elements specified there so how do I get
because you only had two elements
specified in each of the five plus no
yeah right okay fine
and why is those six seven ten eleven
because when you take the tensor but if
you look at the nonzero elements of by
plus right above okay okay
okay so this is ultimately going to be a
2 to the 4 ie 16 dimensional as it says
right there yes okay
they're both that right below you can
see five plus five minus versailles - s
prod these are just and so this is
if you want to specify the states with
the specification specifications you can
do that as a list in quantum by a
dimensional state but if you have
quantum finite dimensional states you
can also just take the product of those
as quantum product because it could turn
out that you have more complicated
quantum states you've developed along
the way by acting on them with circuits
or operations or measurements yes and
you could just take one product of those
with quantum product right there right
so that's equivalent so you're telling
me that if I take quantum product of
let's say I just do just to make sure I
understand what you're talking about if
I say Phi minus here my plus just to be
consistent here and then I do the same
thing again you're saying I do this I
get that so that's equivalent you say to
the more degenerate form of just putting
so I don't quite understand why would I
not just be able to put a quantum finite
eventual state inside this other quantum
finite dimensional split state to
represent that quantum product because
these are I'm trying to think of a way
of putting this so for one you could
have quantum states that are mixed not
pure so you'd have to represent them
with density matrices you know and so
right now there's no way of generating a
quantum finite dimensional State mixed
just from inputting an array you have to
actually create a mixture with quantum
mixture which is below and so if you
wanted to take a quantum product of a
mixture in something else for instance
you know then you need this quantum
product formalism I see I see
I still think that this is a nicer way
of doing things than before where we had
you know the quantum objects goes to you
and quantum product goes to quantum
mixture we had a lot of key words almost
before yeah I think having separate
symbols for these dresses looking at
some I didn't we looked at the Sun we
talked to this person he's at Stanford
actually Oh didn't we talk to this
person I don't think so
maybe I ran into him somewhere I thought
there was some interesting stuff here
but but if we actually worked with the
research group that I'm in right now
okay so maybe you could contact him the
the person on the livestream is claiming
that one is who's numbering states that
he deals with so yeah tensor networks
are a different way of representing
quantum states that's someone distinct
from this which I'm doing right now okay
well can we but it sounds like oh yeah
I've looked at this I think yeah right
well ok but so so can you explain what a
tensor network is ok so the case that
we're interested in is on the matrix
product state which basically you can
represent each quantum object in a large
array or grid or whatever you want to
call lattice of quantum objects by some
type of tensor and the bonds but the car
the couplings between different quantum
objects are represented by these tensor
indices which you can contract and
things like that the reason that tensor
networks are useful is that for certain
types of states and in particular
for lo entanglement states area law
states like the scaling of the
entanglement goes with area which
happened to be there was a physical
interest many times like gramma states
and the lowest excited states can be
represented much more efficiently in
terms of the number of nonzero
components ticket approximation in
tensor networks then they can using full
Hilbert space formalism so let me
understand this again okay so what
you're saying I mean here this is an
outer product I mean the the basis here
is these various outer products of
possible of states is that is that right
mm-hmm
okay so in a tensor network is the is
somehow the basis not represented in
that same way as a as a complete outer
product like that or what you you don't
actually need all of those you what you
do for a tensor network is each of the
tensors you can you have a bunch of
nonzero components for each basically
instead of any state vector you take the
density matrix and you look at that and
you take the eigen spectrum and a lot of
the for low entanglement states a lot of
the eigenvalues will be very close to
zero and you can just discard them to
good approximation and truncate the
dimension of your Hilbert space I say so
it's eigenstates some kind of eigen
essentially eigenvectors of the density
matrix is that right right and you're
keeping the ones that have decently
large eigenvalues or something right
that's a method called notice the
density matrix normalization group which
is used to iteratively truncate the
dimension of the Hilbert space so okay
so let me try to understand that so that
that's this is from what we're doing
right now though okay but I want to
understand that I mean I want to
understand how that relates because
that's another
representation so that's something where
you're where you're backing out from a
bunch of I mean it's a question of what
the I mean what you've got here is
something it's a compression scheme
basically yeah states and quantum states
mmm-hmm it's used a lot in like
high-performance scientific computing
when you're trying to model and simulate
quantum systems of many particles yeah
I've heard about this right I mean this
is this is a sense my time kind of idea
right because back in back in the day
when people were first doing this yeah
this this is a comparatively recent
invention I think um but
I mean a question given that we're
talking about those kinds of things this
is where this starts to intersect with
the things we're trying to do in
computational chemistry and arguably we
should get Jason to join one of these
meetings at some point unless he's gonna
say he only knows about quantum
chemistry are not quantum anything else
um but that okay so in a quantum spin
system for example that the type of
thing you're talking about would be
relevant is that true yes a good if you
if you're looking on github a really
good library that's used a lot for these
type of things is a tensor okay so
that's that's like the the best one that
I know of that that performs these type
of computations well what's the
computation to perform I mean the
computation is is basically doing what
kind of I mean like finding a quantum
ground state given for some system of
the Hamiltonian that's represented where
the states of the system are represented
in this way or what's the idea so there
is the whole algorithm for iteratively
truncating involves sweeping back and
forth along your spin chain or whatever
you know configuration you have and
there are some subtleties there there's
also some subtleties when you time
evolve your system instead of just
finding the static ground state if you
want to continue to maintain your tensor
network representation yeah because
because the ultimate thing is is not the
particular eigenvalues and eigenstates
of this density matrix thing and it
might turn out that you don't anymore
have that the things which are important
and not the things which are the high
lying I ghen states of the density
matrix right in other words the
presumably you have to re sweep it to
find out what the you know to re
represent it in terms of those in terms
of eigenstates like that mm-hmm
I mean in
but let me just try to understand I mean
so how that relates to what we're
talking about here because that's a case
we have a spin chain and you have a
Hamiltonian for the evolution of the
spin chain right right but now in our
case here we don't really have any
hamiltonians insight we just have the
unitary transformations that in
correspond to the discrete time you know
e to the i HT for the hamiltonian right
but presumably for a spin chain you do
the same thing as well I mean I believe
people have made quantum cellular
automata at that kind of way where you
basically are applying a discrete you
know unitary transformation although I'm
what is the relationship between I mean
the confusion of that is always that you
have a local Hamiltonian so which well
that depends only on neighboring spins
but then the final unitary operation is
something that is a big kind of thing
that operates on the outer product
states right and that's why in addition
to having these matrix product states
there's matrix product operators which
are extensions of this tensor network
formalism to operators like Hamiltonians
ok ok so so the basic bottom line is
this is a it's a numerical scheme for
dealing with essentially quantum spin
networks that
ignores essentially the small components
of the states of the altitudes right and
realization group procedure does it
basically you know traces out or
integrates out irrelevant degrees of
freedom that's them well we're a
normalization group has you know has the
other feature that it's actually trying
to do some scale change somewhere which
I don't think is what you're talking
about here I think so this is it's very
loosely based on on that type of
renormalization group procedure nicely
okay fine but but so I mean one of the
bottom lines here the reason I'm pushing
on this a bit is because we need to
understand in our setup here
what's the analog of I mean okay first
of all how will we make a spin chain how
would make the animal wisp engine I
believe you'll register your quantum
register is basically a spin chain
mm-hmm you know what's really outrageous
about this well I worked on all this
nonsense back in 1981 this was exactly
the thing we were doing with quantum
spin chains and trying to figure out the
evolution of quantum spin chains which I
guess is more difficult than um I mean I
guess the thing that one thinks about so
let me just walk me through for my
physics understanding okay so we got a
quantum spin chain which is like a
quantum register true or not true that
it's true yeah okay all right so now in
a one way to do that would be to say
there's an identical Hamiltonian at
every spin on the spin chain mm-hmm and
so what would that look like for so
these various operations
what I mean is it like evolving a
cellular taunton where you're just
taking what what is it like it explained
to me that the hamiltonian at every an
identical hamiltonian it's like an izing
hamiltonian for example right so let's
take a naive let us take a naive
pairwise Hamiltonian which is just well
no let's take the Hamiltonian is you
know for every s sub i let's say times S
sub I plus 1 plus s sub I times S sub I
minus 1 okay so a simple icing like
Hamiltonian yeah you don't actually even
need the second term you just mentioned
because that's degenerate with if you
sell everything fine all right so it's
just the the pairs S sub I is sub I plus
one okay now what so now what does that
correspond to in terms of the quantum
circuit stuff so let's let's spin chain
is going to have a future time step that
is the result of sort of one unit of
time operated on operated according to
the saml tone Ian mm-hmm so what go
ahead
basically you use the local hamiltonians
to generate a global Hamiltonian yeah
and yeah and then you know you would
discretize your you know shorting your
evolution using things like the Hubbard
store on a [ __ ] you know transformation
and things like that um ok so this is
the thing that I remember back from the
distant past of like 1981 this was a
hard thing that is going from the local
Hamiltonian to something reasonable in
terms of a unitary transformation that
wasn't just you take the whole system of
n spins and you figure out the energy
transformation for the whole system of n
spins there wasn't a way to break that
down into sub pieces right and that's
that's why this you know density matrix
remotes or the TDM RG is called the
time-dependent density matrix
normalization group procedure is used ok
but so walk me through what the analog
if if I have a circuit that has a bunch
of you know random you know I don't know
what controlled-not gates or something
between pairs of spins effectively ok
does that correspond to some Hamiltonian
and if so what Hamiltonian so first of
all the hamiltonian is hermitian which
you're not guaranteed that is any
circuit that you generate is hermitian
the circuit is just guaranteed to be
unitary so so you can often that say
that you're not necessarily guaranteed
to have it be any Hamiltonian well so
wait a minute so if you believe that you
have a circuit how do you what is the
time evolution of a circuit given in
other words if you look at how do you
implement a circuit in terms of time
evolution
so generally I'm not entirely sure what
you're saying but if I if I think I
think what you're saying is that in
general like physically what happens is
there's different time steps and at each
time step you perform different
operations in your circuit yeah I
understand that but I'm asking even for
a single time step I want to actually
make my circuit I'm gonna build some
actual circuit and how do i I mean and
the circuit is described by some
Hamiltonian which is a generator of
infinitesimal time translations
basically and the question then is you
know but I actually then make it run
right for some finite non infant
festival time and the result of that is
supposed to be some unitary
transformation that corresponds let's
say to a controlled-not mm-hmm right so
I'm asking you what is the Hamiltonian
that when run for finite time gives you
controlled not
I'm not entirely sure just off the bat I
yeah right I'm suspicious but I think
it's kind of some kind of mess I mean I
think it's one of these things where um
but okay so so we're dealing with a
different level of approximation in the
quantum circuit case where we're just
saying okay there's these blocks of
unitary transformations that are
happening and we're not asking the
question what's the underlying
Hamiltonian right it would be nice to
understand how to pull those things
together for um yeah okay fine all right
so let's put that to the side for a
minute um although all right great
okay let's keep going what is quantum
entangled objects so that's asking
whether what is the one into here so you
take any quantum state which s1 is the
quantum state here which is you know Phi
plus Phi plus and you make some by
partition so here this because you made
this s1 state you generated that again
in above if you take the Phi plus the
one above the s-1 that you chose yes and
then if you go down there because it has
to be a by partition of her system
entangled looking for entanglement in a
quantum state only makes sense if you
take partition and you look across that
okay but so if I take this I just
redefined s1 and if I'm not mistaken one
three three four something like this I
should law why didn't that get announcer
am i confused
that should work I need to look at that
okay
um do you think it will work if I say 1
2 3 4 let's try
suspicious I am okay I don't know what
that's doing okay fine um okay I need to
look at that again okay no problem there
may be above there okay all right
quantum partial trace so that's that
tasting over that that so that your
second qubit in the quantum state
yep okay
so that's my original one there which in
now in this case here should be much
bigger creature yep okay so that's the
density matrix corresponding to the five
plus nine plus right which on one hand
can have a state vector that is then
yeah it's it's sixteen dimensional in
that case it's a length 16 state vector
or it's a 16 by 16 density matrix right
so you could plug in state vector there
and they would do that for you let's try
and see now the matrix form you should
keep okay very nice okay fine so good so
I was just gonna say that the more
interesting stuff is actually a little
bit further down okay okay so this right
here is you're creating a quantum
mixture of s1 and s2 but this is in
terms of symbolic you know weights T and
1 minus T yeah I remember we talked
about this last time of trying to have
those weights not be yeah okay
and then actually if you go down a
little bit further there's actually even
quantum plot which you can manipulate so
we have to define s2 I think it's yeah
want to redo the definition of s1 to be
this angle thinking about today I do
this that will now be length for thing
okay now if you do ya manipulative its
do the manipulate one that is the most
disgustingly you know like business
graphics okay well a graphics person
time just amused I mean it's kind of
like like quantum computing meets you
know business graphics okay in any case
but the general idea is there but
generally there is interesting okay so
the general idea here this is
representing so this quantum mixture you
say and I'm not convinced by the plot
aspect of it there there's quantum
mixture if I said normal of this what
would happen here and a thing so you can
do normal of like the density matrix is
that for instance okay
so let's take percent sixty density
matrix
okay very nice actually above right
there that's s3 density matrix like
three lines above yeah okay fine it's
nice okay okay
all right let's keep going here state
distance yeah so there's a bunch of
different methods you can use to measure
the distance between quantum states and
how do they relate to our other distance
measures so I mean like for example so
one of the options is Euclidean distance
and I think below you there's a list of
them I'm actually just like a couple
lines below okay but there's a whole
gaggle of these some you see if you go
down a little bit further
just a little bit more there you go what
are these things I mean all the ways
that I could find where people when
people actually use to measure distance
between quantum states right but does an
analogous to our things like you know
binary distance or Manhattan distance or
something like that here
so I mean if I were to say something so
I'm just trying to understand the design
here if I say Manhattan distance between
you know 1 2 3 and 3 2 1 okay so what
you're saying is maybe instead of coming
up with my own quantum state distance
symbol maybe I should try to work it out
by having it integrate with the thinking
but I don't even know whether there's
any sense so explain to me what what one
of these methods like the I don't know
the fidelity what what is what what is
this computing I mean if I have the
quantum states be you know vectors of
length 4 or something is this just a
mathematical computation like this
Manhattan distances it's a mathematical
computation um but it's something that
is so for instance the fidelity is used
to tell after you perform a computation
on the quantum state that you can take
the input and like the are the output
and what the ideal expected output was
and you computes a measure of like how
close the two are by it ends up being
something like taking the matrix square
root of the density matrices and
products of those density matrices is it
the case that this thing is basically
taking two vectors with a bunch of
parameters in them and working out you
know some computation that could could
as well be worked out on a on just a
pure you know random vector or is this
something where you need other
attributes of that quantum state to know
what this distance measure should be so
if you have pure States that's true
but if you have mixed States then you
can't represent your state by a vector
anymore
right okay fair enough okay but then
these things I see I mean we're having a
bit of a conflict here of how many
symbols we should be introducing and how
many that's why above at the beginning
of the document I have a list of all the
ones they're absolutely necessary and
all the ones that are you know ancillary
that would be nice to have but or not
miss I mean so when you say different
methods here I mean is is it the case
that these are somehow supposed to be
sort of the same thing or are they are
these really measuring completely
different things they're measuring
completely different things but they're
all you know you know they all satisfy
you know the properties that any metric
must satisfy well okay so they're pretty
much directly analogous to these things
and each one in the case of matrix in
the case of vectors would have some rate
that is a pure sort of mathematical form
I might say without the metadata exactly
I think these are notions of distance in
the space of hermitian matrices
basically yeah okay so we have a notion
of a matrix distance as I recall some of
these distances operate on on matrices
just in the Frobenius norm for matrices
for example it's very not here it would
be norm
oh that's a norm as in for single matrix
right right here we could say took a
half a distance as the norm of a
difference of material right but these
distances are not defined in that way
they are like traces of square roots of
matrices and things of that now
that's the way that works okay I mean
yeah it's not obvious
you know method options typically mean
you're going to get the same answer more
or less but it might be more efficient
or there might be some arbitrary thing
about whether you draw the jagged line
in this way or that way
or whether you draw so they don't tend
to be intending to you know represent
really different you know really
different results but let's come back to
this um you know somewhat shocking I
need to get myself music chocolate I am
otherwise not going to be able to
continue thinking properly I will be
right back please continue so perhaps I
think what Stephen was saying is that
perhaps you can have a third argument
for the distance function rather than a
method option okay that backward I don't
know whether we have a precedent for
that in any of the our distance
functions
all right so this is the Bloch sphere
business mm-hmm can I do that with more
than yeah as many as you want you can
even you could put in I think s3 was the
mixed state comes you can add in s3
there so one two
it just it automatically normalizes
everything so one two is really one over
square root 3 2 over square root 3 okay
so if I were to go here just so I
understand this picture if I would say
well this because you have to to plot
style arguments that should be fixed you
it shouldn't care about them you should
just use the ones it has okay um and
arguably okay I mean this this
particular thing we're really gonna have
this thing and by the way the fact that
the sphere is so far away from its I
know you mentioned that before I don't
know how to fix that but well somebody
can help you with that yes it's a lot of
these graphics things that say it seems
like you know the visualizations is not
my strong suit so but it's more the idea
that I'm trying to get at hmm okay so
that's one zero representing now if I
were to take this as a four dimensional
object so then you can't actually do it
on the Bloch sphere because okay that's
not a qubit um so this only works for
cube it's exactly which is why the
quantum block plot is also one of the
not necessary but would be nice
functions now I mean given that you're
doing this in principle like Keolis plot
you can unravel this Bloch sphere onto a
projection right okay I don't see why
you can't you can obviously do then
isn't there some way
isn't this block sphere isn't the
conformal board is it called the UM oh
gosh what the heck is the projection
where you we shine a light source at the
top what is that called you know what
I'm talking about so what I think or
something
mm-hmm no there's another term for it in
complex analysis it's their
stereographic stereographic um
I don't know that's illuminating in this
case but that's certainly something you
know in terms of pure visualization that
could be so that would represent in a
direct product state of the kind that
you are described that's supposed to be
a direct private state is that correct
no so for quantum block plot you just
you list the different states that you
want on the plot oh I see so that's why
I said you could even add in s3 there
and then you know like yellow or
something and even though s3 is a mixed
state it's still cubed so it will still
plot on the Bloch sphere it would just
not be on the out like the edge of the
Bloch sphere no I say that's interesting
okay well so much for my projection idea
and that's because the normalization of
the thing is I mean it's not that you're
saying it's not a unit vector on the
sphere by the time it's a mixed state
exactly okay and completely fully mixed
states actually reside directly the
center of the sphere mm-hmm okay all
right so there's a okay so let's keep
going here so this is all stuff about
states right so if you go down further
you know we saw the quantum matrix
operation stuff
the quantum circuits now you can make it
out of quantum operation like quantum
matrix operations and data boolean
functions and I'm working on adding in
quantum algorithms like you know you
could put in like like deutsches
algorithm or Grover's algorithm or sure
or something like that with some
specifications and somewhat funky
notation here so you need to put in
which qubits or cute it's each of your
operations is acting on right I mean it
feels like something like okay so in
functional programming how would we do
that
answer it's something like the curry
operation isn't it
Hosea don't you think because curry
would say I've got my F and I'm going to
operate on a certain me remind myself
how curry works yes it would be a list
of numbers basically right notice that I
get see that multiplication sign there
that is a baguette that needs to be
squash yes yes that's probably a for
Sushma thing okay so this is like two
three to four or something here yes in
general
fermentation but it also be three to
four and then it will wait for four
arguments and take the third the second
the fourth okay so what we've got here
is two functions what would we do let's
imagine that quantum circuit just to the
composition okay I'm let's call it f X
and F F top okay so it's FX is acting on
[Music]
the first so the thing we've got here if
it was a list see I'm a little bit
confused because that's a curried oh boy
let's say our quantum function really
was acting on one two three four okay
there was really a four or a function
I'm making sense yeah but we wanted to
break that function down
what have we done with neural networks
for this
how does net chain refer to its to the
elements boy there's a bunch of buckets
here in this prototype version but you
understand my question I mean when we're
doing things here I guess it's all the
different is it different I mean that
these are successive layers that are
operating on you know the wires that
come out of one layer this is a little
different because this is saying well
now I could have the toughly gate act on
one couldn't die as well
there'd be nothing wrong with doing
something like this is that good you can
absolutely do that you would just make a
different circuit diagram yeah yeah I
understand okay fine so what this is
saying is we've got two functions so you
get my analogy with with the UM
functional programming thing right so
maybe we could think about this as being
a function of four arguments okay what
is the circuit is the circuit sorry the
difference is that we need the function
to return four arguments again so that
again yeah right so I mean in the case
of boolean function we would do
something like this by the way the
background noise what we could to mutant
um okay so that's all well and good that
boolean function has three arguments the
problem is it's not I see okay that's
very interesting that's life in the
quantum world the functions don't return
a single result
well what is the thing that represents
an identity the state here so this is
returning is I'm saying if I if I say
operate with that function on one
quantum state I'm getting out another
quantum state if I understand correctly
so this is something that I'm currently
working on is instead of operating with
the quantum circuit on the quantum state
with in the same way that we get
properties if the quantum circuit that's
where quantum evaluate comes in but I
think what you're meant what you're
talking about is when I do quantum
evaluate of the circuit and right now it
works for quantum operations so if you
put in like X goes to 1 and then you did
like s1 or something that acted on the
quantum state and changed it okay so I
should say this goes to 2 here so that's
because of that quantum state you're
using time so much you're probably right
ok all right ok fine
but this will generalized quantum
circuits where you can just say circuit
and then quantum state and you'll be
able to evaluate like that and then
there should be an option that specifies
whether you want the result to be a
quantum state like the quantum register
that I showed you in the boolean circuit
case or you want to actually put your
result into a classical register meaning
measure it ok but look I mean this
notation of there's a very weird
notation at some level because what we
have normally is something like the
function function what do we have
normally I mean
so the problem here is that because we
have this need of returning several
things rather than a function approach
it's better to have a transformation
approach like the geometric
transformations that take vectors and
return vectors so so here we need this
disapper this more symmetric approach of
taking vectors rather than arguments
okay fair enough or it's more like
something like a a matrix product or
something right so in other words your
claim is that we basically have to
represent the the states are like lists
right okay let's take a look at what
that would look like let's say we got a
list ABCD and we've got functions that
act on sub parts of that list do we have
a precedent is it basically sparse
arrays sparse array bicycles precedent
I'm saying because if we will say we
have a transformation matrix acting on
this a sparse array of let's say you
know one one goes to you know P 1 1 3 4
goes to P 1 2 P 3 4 let's say and then
that gives us a sparse array which can
then act on ABCD
that's very weird result why oh I see
because it isn't a 4x4 okay all right so
that is an analogy in my opinion to what
we're doing here that is that's saying
these are the matrix rows and columns
that this particular in this case just
pure product thing is going to act on
that makes sense
mm-hmm so I think the analog here the
the correct form of quantum evaluate and
I think actually it's better hmm I don't
know if quantum evaluation is right um
but but you know the thing it would be
is quantum evaluate of and then the
analog of this which is not a precise
analog
as something like that so you're just
reversing the order that's what I'm
think I'm saying yes okay I mean does
that make sense - I mean I think this is
our closest analogue to this kind of
behavior okay also I just wanted to
point out quite evaluate the reason that
I decided on that name and I'm very open
to other suggestions is because one
that's the name that you mentioned in
your post okay well it's good
okay then because in addition to you
having this be a classical simulation
right now we are simulating quantum
computation on a classical computer
through Mathematica but we also were
talking about the possibility of
integrating this with an actual home
computer or API yeah somebody could
actually deliver that to us right and so
if if we want that to be the case one
possibility would be to have an option
that says quantum evaluate back-end goes
to and then we can add the quantum
computer thing because that's how it's
done in the Python quantum information
science kit that I was talking about
which does integrate with IBM quantum
experience they say back-end goes to you
really has anybody actually seen it run
yes I've actually I've used it before
with an actual quantum computer not a
simulator at the back yeah it returns
for you results on the performance and
you can also specify number of trials
which is another option that we should
support fascinating those guys are
promised to get us access to that thing
for what is it three years now it's
fascinating and unfortunately I do have
to go I will okay I got quite a bit more
to do here
all right well we'll have to continue
another time yes um all right good stuff
okay
in terms of the quantum neural Nets I
was reading a lot of papers on Emma
trying to figure out okay well that was
my challenge to you is whether this
formalism can support those things so I
think but there's one thing that just
I'll mention now and we can you know
ruminate on until next time is
supporting control flow in a quantum
circuit instead of just having
operations and measurements um because
one thing that you need not just for
sure okay so do you think you know how
to do control flow I don't know how to
do that at this point
does anybody I don't know I'm sure I've
never heard of it yeah I mean it is
because these things are usually
straight line you know they're just
straight line programs especially if we
want to actually be like have this go
through an actual quantum computer I'm
not sure if that's possible but that's
something that you do need um in order
to from what I think when it's far away
from doing able to do that just like
this is the thing that basically does
boolean functions I mean that's what the
current formalism is about mm-hmm but in
order to for instance stimulate
non-linearity in a quantum circuit you
need to do something called a repeating
until success procedure like just like a
general recursive function that has to
you know has it has to have some kind of
new operator type thing anyway okay
let's let's wrap it up for right now um
and um okay so people who are on the
live stream
until next time see you later and let's
take it from there all right